so one of the the the muscles that good
leaders uh develop is Believe It or Not
empathy
um so what does empathy look and sound
like in a corporate environment
um it doesn't mean walking around crying
it's not what it means
um it means being able to see another
person as a human being not just as a
cognitive machine so for example here's
a fairly common scenario in in a in a
business you know
um a manager walks into somebody's
office and says um you've missed your
numbers this quarter you know we've had
this conversation three three times
before and if you don't hit your numbers
the next quarter I don't know what's
going to happen right that's a fairly
normal uh scenario if you inject empathy
into that scenario it goes a little
differently the manager walks into the
office or calls them up and says you
know you've missed your numbers for the
third time in a row we've had this
conversation before are you okay I'm
worried about you what's going on
um that's that's a a muscle that has to
be developed where that person feels
that someone has their back that someone
cares for them and that pays back in
spades over the course of time and
people will give their Blood Sweat and
Tears uh to serve and give back and
follow a leader
um who they believe sees them as a human
being and cares about their well-being
as a human being
not just if they're hitting their
numbers good leaders are students of
leadership
and and they're fascinated by the
subject they read books they watch talks
they're constantly talking about the
subject and companies do have a
responsibility I believe to offer some
of that training
um you know good leadership training
includes skills like and I mentioned
some of these before you know um how to
uh uh resolve conflict how to have uh an
effective confrontation what happens if
something goes wrong where somebody did
something badly like how do you tell
them in a way that they'll hear that
information rather than just be
defensive you know how to have an
effective confrontation how to have a
difficult conversation
um how to listen uh active listening
where you listen for meaning rather than
listening for Words these are learnable
teachable skills and yes uh whatever
training department or HR uh facility
you have should provide that training as
you make your way through through the
formal rank structure so that you are
equipped for the new job you have just
like we would if you were a in a
technical job
um so yeah that's that's part of it but
also people who are who like I said who
aspire to be leaders they do their own
studying one of the things that I've
seen very successful in many companies
and it's very inexpensive in fact it's
very close to free is uh is a book club
where somebody says I want to be a
better leader
um they choose to read a particular book
and people volunteer and they read two
or three chapters a week and get
together at lunchtime or whatever on
Friday after work and they talk about
the chapters and they just have a book
club and slowly but surely that book
club grows and then finally somebody
says you know what this was such a good
book I bet I could teach a class to
other people about the subject of this
book and before you know it you have a
homegrown leadership training program
I've seen that work very very very
successfully and it's very very simple
to implement a book club